pequeña informado hoy de
31.44 nuevos casos la cifra no solo
cruza el umbral psicológico de los
30.000 sino que además bate el récord
registrado el 13 de abril fecha en la
que fue encerrada por un brote
descontrolado el cuadro Ahora parece más
complejo no bastará con encerrar a 25
millones de habitantes como Entonces
porque los contagios están mucho más
repartidos en ciudades como Pekín en el
norte chonchin en el centro One Joe en
el sur la crisis le llega a China apenas
dos semanas después de haber relajado su
política de cero covid acortó la
cuarentena para los contactos primarios
eximió de ella a Los secundarios y te
aconsejó a las ciudades que siguieran
practicando los test masivos sin embargo
el agravamiento de los brotes existentes
y la aparición de nuevos han obligado a
poner en pausa las nuevas políticas
preocupa la situación de Pekín que vive
ya en un estado de
el confinamiento desde el fin de semana
a anunciado la muerte de cuatro personas
las primeras que sufre el país en casi
seis meses y los casos no han dejado de
subir a pesar de todas las restricciones
aprobadas estamos ya por encima de los
1.600 casos y no hay ningún indicio de
que la tendencia vaya a revertir por eso
las autoridades ya se han preparado para
lo peor han acondicionado un centro de
convenciones enormes en las afueras como
hospital y están levantando
construcciones en el centro para
acomodar a los contagiados y sus
contactos